la deuxième vague épidémique prend une
ampleur inédite en inde depuis début
avril le nombre de contaminations
qu'ovide 19 a plus que doublé pour
atteindre le chiffre inédit de 200 mille
nouveaux cas en 24 heures
l'inde devient le deuxième pays le plus
touché par le cos vite 19 en termes de
nouvelles contaminations par jour
dépassant le brésil
conséquence l'état du maharashtra et sa
capitale économique bombay ont instauré
un confinement les week-ends et un
couvre feu nocturne couvre-feu également
à new delhi la capitale du pays en cette
période de fêtes religieuses et
notamment de ramadan pour les musulmans
les autorités craignent une aggravation
de la situation sanitaire
c'est triste cette année mais si le
gouvernement impose des restrictions aux
gens c'est évidemment pour notre bien
pour que nous soyons à l'abri du
coronavirus si nous suivons toutes les
précautions de sécurité cette année
alors au moins l'année prochaine notre
ramadan sera bon si nous ne resterons
pas l'année prochaine sera pire que
celle ci cette année la différence c'est
que les rues ne sont pas aussi animé
qu'avant mais à la maison où nous prions
et observons notre jeune comme nous le
ferions autrement la situation est
sombre
ce n'est plus comme avant les gens ne
sortent pas de chez eux c'est troublant
de voir la mosquée de new delhi ceilidh
alors qu'elle est normalement rempli de
monde
les autorités du maharashtra envisage un
confinement total six le nombre de
contaminations ne baisse pas la campagne
vaccinale ne va pas aussi vite que prévu
mais va s'accélérer avec l'autorisation
récente sur le marché de spoutnik vais
pas été relevé l'actrice avec finn a
marre d'échouer dans un développement
positif un troisième vaccin était
approuvé pour une utilisation d'urgence
en langues
le vaccin ce qui inquiète il saisit une
collaboration entre la russie les landes
après beaucoup d'efforts pour un dîner
du nfc du vaccin les essais se sont
déroulés de manière satisfaisante à les
capter colleter à trequesser
bac 5 en trois groupes nous espérons et
nous invitons les fabricants de vaccins
tels que pfizer moderna johnson &
johnson et d'autres qui en sont à
d'autres étapes et qui demanderont
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché à
l'une de ces agences à être prêts à
venir en inde le plus tôt possible
alternance parce que les premières doses
du vaccin russes seront disponibles à la
fin du mois d'avril et il y a urgence
pour l'instant dans ce pays d'un
milliard trois cents millions
d'habitants 108 millions de doses de
vaccin anti qu'ovide ont déjà été
administrées au total 175 mille
personnes sont mortes du coronavirus en
inde